hi hello congratulations first of all
thank you
the earth
uh that what what do you say the the the
sun revolved around the earth right vice
versa
you know so when you have modern but the
centristic
i'm not concerned about the specifics
sir right right
[Applause]
we must stop the terror
i call upon all nations to do everything
they can
to stop these terrorist killers
thank you
now watch this drive
hello hi what's your name my name is
anita anita lovely and uh where do you
live anita i live in manchester and it's
my birthday today
why does she want a prize
we were all born
who is the biggest diva in the whole
cast
oh why do you why did she say she feels
like she knows what answer do you think
you know yeah well who who do you think
it is okay i want to know what she
thinks yeah who do you think
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much first of all um
i don't even know if i want this award i
might just take christina home tonight
i mean this man who would pay that has
anyone paid 99 just for the image that's
how the gold that's how the image is on
your face your people from your show
page now what
idiots it's a love song to portland
right so you're like you know he's like
okay that's something i can grab onto
that's one little tiny little thing
something so i just started off and i
for some reason i felt william shatner
come over me right
which happened
if someone yeah
the whole thing is just like about
annoying people like when people tweet
it's very easy to piss off one side the
art is
you got to try to get everybody
so you tweet stuff like trump is such a
dope he's actually gonna make me vote
for a woman
right
and then you just sit back
when my wife and i need alone time we
tell the kids oh we tell the kids that
we're going camping
yeah slang word for
are you a billionaire yet steve you've
got to be a billionaire i've just been
trying to add it all up well if i was a
billionaire i wouldn't be on your show
yeah i want to tell that lady as well
can you stop filming me with a video
camera because i'm really here in real
life you can enjoy it in real life
[Applause]
[Applause]
south korea has done five times more
tests than the u.s per capita why is
that i don't think that's true that is
true and you said this morning that the
white house said the u.s passes south
korea in virus testing who are you with
yahoo news and it's not true per capita
uh do you want to respond to that if you
have the numbers south korea's testing
was 11
per
per a hundred thousand and we're at 17
per hundred thousand all right so are
you going to apologize yahoo that's why
you're yellow and nobody knows
go ahead i just remember i liked you and
he was like
not now um
i'm married now um but he was like oh
well you can meet i mean i don't know
i can't tell you what she says okay
let's let me hear them she's in my deal
i'm in your dance
i'm probably one of the millions
if that's the case you know what she
says
she says even though i'm spanish you
know i like that chocolate
but does that work
no
and i tell her once you go shaq you
never go back
when you want something i get the
feeling you go for it has i never told
you this couch is is not as comfortable
as it looks
yeah i mean
look
you want to go like jumping on couches
i want to thank uh my wife blake who is
sitting right there
who is everything to me
uh
you are the best thing the best thing
that has ever happened to me
second only to this star on the
hollywood clock of fame
it's the hollywood walk of fame got me
some slack here um
and you're talking about
you know the devil something uh the
devil will show up but we're continuing
to do god's work do you believe in the
devil definitely what do you think the
devil is like
president
you've had your driver's license taken
away a few times because of some
infraction like no i know i know you're
asking me a serious question i swear to
goodness i was in court today renewing
my driver's license again because it got
suspended i'm a speed demon you're a
speed demon i don't i don't respect the
law and i don't feel like i have to
because i'm i'm a sex symbol now when
you do this
the number one betty white tip for
living a long and happy life
don't waste your time watching this crap
[Applause]
why is boston called bean
it sounded town uh
we were at the aquarium
most used app on your phone
oh um the podcast
sure podcast
one more time with the gesture please
it's cbs we have to blur that i think
what podcast are you listening to and
send me some links
[Music]
what you think about lady gaga it feels
uh reductive
is that good
look it up
i'm working on my body and i just don't
like i have chocolate i'm lying yeah see
yeah
and then it turns you on no it doesn't
you just said he did no i didn't mean it
in that way okay
[ __ ]
all right
21 years old he was in a mcdonald's
going you want lids on these
everybody's different but
it's worth in that now here can you pick
it up out of here yeah sure i'll pick it
up for you here no while you're down
there
so when you were cycling in amsterdam
you didn't could you go up near the red
light district
oh yeah i'll visit i'm i'm a big fan of
porn i okay
and i would say people always ask me uh
because i'm tall if i play basketball
mine is worse i go i always say hey your
face is all
up
do you box
that's pretty good it was mean yeah yeah
it was before i hadn't found my way it's
so hard you have to get that laugh up
top another one is do they say how's the
weather up there and you say it's
raining and you spit in their face
i went and saw a bunch of shows
and i saw everybody uh-huh i didn't see
mariah because at the time she wasn't
playing she hadn't started yet who but i
saw britney i saw shania no i'm playing
because that's what mariah said about
jennifer one time i'm not trying to
start anything
she does say that yeah she's just
forgetful i guess yes
i don't know i went to that prize club
once i never seen a roast or anything
like that joy but i see i went one time
i loved playing poker i had a bit of a
gambling problem for a while and i
couldn't get enough poker games right so
this dude he told me you gotta go to the
friars club man there's a big poker game
there right i have to talk to four
people here so so uh so i go to the to
the friars club barbara are you
listening yeah
[Applause]
so i go there and there's all these old
dudes there right and they're all comics
from like 50 years ago and i don't know
who the hell they are you know and it's
not like famous comics like milton berle
or anybody like that it's these b level
comics from 50 years ago you know like a
freddie roman and dudes like that right
so they're all playing poker you know
they're all playing poker and i'm
playing poker i just want to play poker
but they're all like making jokes you
know and every joke they're making
involves me being a gay dude
[Music]
here's a you know be like a queen i'd
get a queen
here's a lady for the lady
[Applause]
and they'd all laugh you know and i
didn't notice at first i'm just playing
cards and all of a sudden i realized
every joke is me being a homosexual man
right so i'm not a homosexual man as you
well know
[Applause]
he's definitely not you're not no i'm
not i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not
well let me tell you something else i
would have sex with you while you were
awake
[Applause]
thank you